the state fair of texas sells over half
a million corn dogs per year
that's because they claimed to have sold
the first corn dog ever
back in 1942 everyone in texas will tell
you that the corny dog is the most
delicious corn dog they've ever had
today i'm going to try the og corny dog
along with some traditional saltwater
taffy
and a funnel cake bacon cheeseburger to
tell you which is my favorite
the winner might surprise you let's dig
in
i'm skylar bouchard for the past eight
years i've been traveling the world and
learning about different cuisines
i've taken everything i've learned to my
kitchen and now i'm on the hunt for the
best
festival and fair foods in north america
today
i'm at the state fair of texas the
longest running fair in the entire
country the state fair of texas is the
biggest state fair in america
with over 2 million people attending
each fall they also offer more food than
almost
any state fair in the country the state
fair of texas was founded in 1886 as a
livestock exposition
we have hundreds of concessionaires out
here with thousands of food items on
their menus
even if you're not from here you know as
they say i may not have been born in
texas but i got here as quick as i could
i tried everything from fried butter to
fried peanut butter and jelly but i
narrowed it down to three final
contenders
one of the reasons the state fair of
texas is so famous
is because it debuted one of the most
important fair foods of all time
the corn dog in 1938 brothers neil and
carl fletcher claimed to have invented
the corn dog which they called the corny
dog
that year the idea of a hot dog covered
in corn and deep fried was so unheard of
that they had to walk around the fair
giving them away for free
in order to get people to try them first
year
they sold a couple hundred of them once
they finally got people to try them
and now we sell about anywhere between
500 and 600 000 corny dogs a year we go
through about
1600 gallons of mustard about 800
gallons of ketchup
i've heard people say that they've
waited up to an hour
hour and a half back in line we got
generations that come out here
year after year after year after year
i've been buying them since 1950s
so that's one reason no they're still
just as good as it was then
they're actually hand dipped in
cornbread batter
and i know it's a southern thing it's
delicious there's none other that tastes
like this
they're the best they're crunchy good
always hot
they just taste better than any corn dog
you're gonna get anywhere else i grew up
eating corn dogs
all the time so i'm really excited to
try the one and only
corny dog
[Music]
all right there's a lot of flavor
happening here
and it's not as sweet as the other corn
dogs i've had before the hot dog is
smoky and savory
all in all this is a winner i can
definitely see why people would wait
hours for this corn dog
while this corn dog was delicious i'll
be interested to see if it's really my
favorite since it's so simple
and i have two other unique contenders
to try time to see how the hidden gem
compares
sutter's taffy started back in 1919 and
they still use
old-fashioned methods and machines to
make their delicious
saltwater taffy ed sutter founded
sutter's taffy after working at an
amusement park as a kid
he saw the taffy pullers there making
small pieces of taffy which they called
kisses
and then he bought his own taffy pulling
machines and went on the road
sutter's taffy quickly became extremely
successful selling over
one million boxes of taffy at the 1939
world's fair
tony king and his family bought the
business from sutter's granddaughter in
2008
but they still used the same methods
that sutter did back then
so we bring in a 660 pound barrels of
corn syrup
and so we batch each pot with corn syrup
sugar and butter
and then we put it on our taffy pullers
to aerate it and that's where we flavor
it
at the state fair texas we will make
over a million kisses
so i go in like this pull it down
and it's fresh we make candy every day
right here on the state fairgrounds
this is the candy you made that we just
made just made oh my gosh
all right i have to try one we just made
these this is the peanut butter
[Music]
it's perfect it's so sick sticky and
smooshy
salty sweet oh salty sweet creamy
delicious
it's like it's like peanut butter and
marshmallow spread
finally i'm heading to a fair stand
that's known for its bizarre flavor
combos
time to see which will take the final
crown the classic
corny dog simple salt water taffy or
our wacky snack the wackiest snack at
the state fair of texas is the funnel
cake
bacon queso burger which won the most
creative big tex award
and the best savory dish award back in
2017.
this burger is an estimated 2100
calories
i got in the kitchen to see how it's
made are you ready to make it
i am ready to make a funnel cake queso
burger
well every year we're looking for the
most fantastic
outrageous thing we can find to put out
there
that will make fairgoers say wow little
funnel cakes
awesome grilled burger crispy strips of
bacon and then some really hot
queso sauce so it's uh the simplicity of
it is what works so well together here
we go
now the only other thing we need is our
little knife that holds it all together
right in the um all right ready there
you go
yeah nice work that was awesome
let's see here okay
all right some thoughts
the funnel cake is crispy and sweet it's
char grilled smoky delicious burger the
bacon adds that fat which is flavor
everybody loves a waterfall of cheese
this all came together
so well honestly i always get skeptical
of
the sweet and savory burgers this is
better than i thought it would be
and it had way more flavor than i
thought it would have it really
is a once in a lifetime experience
[Music]
it's really a competition between the
old and the new we have the first ever
corny dog
sutter's historic salt water taffy and
then
this new fusion of the funnel cake queso
burger
but i have to say my favorite one was
the funnel cake
bacon queso burger i love saying that
you know you come to these fairs and you
want to eat foods that are an experience
and it was really just that
it had so much going on and obviously it
had some fried food
some meat some cheese things i love
i loved getting behind the counter and
learning how it was made
and eating it was truly an experience
that you could only get at the state
fair of texas
we'll see you next time stay hungry
[Music]
you